[موسيقى]
هذا هو Huawei mate 30 Pro الجديد ، هذا
هو أحدث هاتف رائد من
Huawei ، الشركة التي ربما سمعت عنها في
عناوين الأخبار لأنهم نوعًا ما في
مأزق هم تحت
القائمة السوداء التجارية الأمريكية مما يعني أنهم لا يستطيعون  الحصول على
الكثير من التكنولوجيا لهواتفهم ولكن
عليهم الاستمرار في طرحها ، لذا
فقد تم إصدار هذا الأمر وسيتم
طرحه في الأسواق الدولية وهذا
الهاتف هو كل شيء عن الكاميرا ، هناك
أربع كاميرات موجودة في التصميم الدائري
في  مرة أخرى ، لديك
عدسة تليفوتوغرافي واسعة للغاية وعدسة استشعار عمق ثلاثية الأبعاد ،
لذلك وجدت أنه عندما
كنت أستخدم الهاتف أحيانًا
كنت سألتقطه لتشغيله وسأضع
إصبعي هناك  لأنه في
مكان مضحك على الهاتف ، ولكن
يقال إن هذا الهاتف يلتقط صورًا مذهلة ،
فهي مميزة ، فهي حادة
الألوان نابضة بالحياة ،
يمكنك تكبيرها ويمكنني رؤية
تفاصيل الأشخاص الذين يمشون بعيدًا
وإذا كنت تريد تجربة  عدسة يمكنك
تبديل ذلك  والتقط صورة بهذه
الطريقة الآن ، أحد أكثر
الميزات شيوعًا على الهواتف الذكية الرائدة هذه
الأيام هو وضع الصورة هذا ، لذا عندما
يمكنك الحصول على هذا العمق الرائع حقًا ، فإن
هذه الكاميرا تعمل بشكل رائع حقًا في هذا
الوضع ، حتى أننا أخذناها من أجل  تدور
ضد Samsung Note 10 plus وكانت
شركة Samsung تعمل بشكل أفضل في الإضاءة الكاملة ولكن
في الليل ، كان 30 مايو
أفضل قليلاً ، كانت الخطوط أكثر وضوحًا ، وكان هناك
نزيف أقل على الجانبين هناك ، لذا يمكن لهذه
الكاميرا حقًا تقديم شيء واحد الآن
حاولت أن تفعل مع تصميم هذا
الهاتف هو جعله تجربة سلسة حقًا
حتى أزالوا زر الصوت ،
لقد وجدت أن هذا أمر
محبط حقًا في محاولة العثور على
مستوى الصوت الذي حصلت عليه بنقرة مزدوجة ، ثم
عليك أن تبقي إصبعك على  الجانب الموجود
هناك لرفع
مستوى الصوت وخفضه لم يكن في الواقع
تجربة مستخدم رائعة ولكن بالطبع
إحدى المشكلات الرئيسية لهذا huawei mate
30 Pro ، تراها هناك على
الصفحة الرئيسية هناك  لا يوجد Google في أي
مكان يعمل فيه نظام تشغيل Android
لأنه نظام تشغيل مفتوح
ولكن لا يوجد متجر Google Play ،
ولا يمتلك هذا الهاتف إمكانية الوصول إلى أشياء
مثل خدمات Google للجوال Gmail
وخرائط Google والكثير من التطبيقات التي يستخدمها الأشخاص بشكل
منتظم  كما أنه لا يحتوي على
Instagram أو Facebook أو whatsapp
وستكون هذه مشكلة كبيرة
لبيع هذا الهاتف في أي سوق
خارج الصين
[موسيقى]